everything that the left is trying to do
is a threat to who we are as the nation
everything that we are built on all the
principles that were built on is on the
line when it comes to the policies that
the radical left is putting forward and
if we don't stop those the next
generation our children and our
grandchildren aren't going to know the
same America that we know hey hey
welcome this is the Ben Shapiro show
Sunday special I'm really excited to
welcome to the program Liz wheeler from
oann one America News Network and her
show is called tipping point she's a
brand new book out also called tipping
points plural to distinguish it from her
show Liz thanks so much for stopping by
Ben thanks for having me so what
prompted you to write your book tipping
points right so this is this is the most
common question I'm asked about this
book and it's actually a great story
and you probably experienced this too
actually after my show every night we
have a show Monday through Friday I get
dozens if not hundreds of emails from
people telling me I agree with what you
say I see for myself what the left is
doing to our nation but how do I do
anything about it these are people who
don't work in Washington DC people who
aren't in the government they're not in
the swamp they want to know what they
can do besides every year going out and
casting their ballot and you know I
would answer as many of those as
possible but after a while I thought
well this needs a longer form so my book
is my long form answer to those people
this is a handbook for what everybody in
America can do to fight back against the
radical leftist ideology so in a second
I'm going to ask you to go through some
of the arguments that you make in the
book and I also want to ask you what
exactly is the mentality that the other
person that you're talking with has to
have in order for any of these arguments
to effective
I'll see that in just one second first I
love my hulex sleep mattress the fact is
I need more sleep I need more time with
my Helix sleep mattress why because it
is fantastic why is it so great you ask
well because it's personalized it just
for me you see helix sleep has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper or a
hot sleeper whether you like that plush
or firm bed with helix no more confusion
no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by GQ and
Wired magazine and by me CNN called it
the most comfortable mattress they've
ever slept on and they do a lot of
sleeping because they're not doing a lot
of journalism over there just go to
helix sleep comm /ban take their two
minutes sleep quiz they will match you
to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life for couples helix can even
split that mattress down the middle I'll
provide you individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they've
got a 10 year warranty you get to try it
out for 100 nights at risk-free so what
more do I have to tell you here they'll
even pick it up for me if you don't love
it I promise you will helix is offering
up to 125 bucks off all mattress orders
for our listeners up to 125 bucks off at
helix sleep comm / Ben that's helix
sleep comm / Ben for up to 125 bucks off
your mattress order helix sleep comm /
Ben so let's talk about what it takes to
even get into the conversation so I get
the same letters that you do the biggest
question I always get is how do I
destroy somebody to feed somebody in one
of these debates and the first thing
that I always ask is is it even
worthwhile having the conversation what
do you think are the preconditions to
having an honest conversation one of
them might be that you're not supposed
to be destroying each other in the
conversation right well one of the
things that I always remind people is a
lot of times when you're having a debate
and this I'm sure you've experienced is
you may not change the mind of the
person that you're actually talking to a
lot of times it's almost entertainment
it's a show to have those ideas compete
with each other and the person that
you're talking to is going to be pretty
firm in their beliefs that's part of
human nature we don't like to change our
minds we don't like to lose face but if
you really think about the people that
are listening what they might hear what
part of the leftist argument they might
need debunked in order to process the
information from your side from the
right side that you're presenting in
that argument that's what I always tell
people to think about not necessarily
the person that you're talking to but
everybody listening to the argument or
the debate so how much commands you have
to have of the facts in order to have
these debates because you spend your
life doing this I spend my life doing
this most of the people who are writing
us spend 5 minutes or 10 minutes or
maybe it out or listening to our shows
every night what level of expertise do
you think people have to have in order
to do do well in these cut these sorts
of conversations well I always say when
you're talking to a liberal it's not
difficult to be the smartest person in
the room the most educated person in the
room
so I would say you do have to know what
you're talking about of course if you
don't know what you're talking about
then you're just gonna be slinging
around talking points kind of makes us
know better in a political debate than
the other side but that's what I hope to
do in my book is I give people some
facts and some figures and some
arguments that you can make without
spending six or eight hours researching
every day before you engage in that
debate and once you know the basics once
you know how to use the
basics almost weaponize that data or
that information against a leftist then
you don't have to you mean you don't
have to have a PhD in politics to do it
have you ever found yourself convinced
by any of the arguments that other
people are making on the other side when
you have a conversation with them on
some of these issues probably not at
this point in my show because I'm pretty
firm I'm pretty I'm pretty firm in my
principles I know what I believe and
more more than that I know why I believe
what I believe I always say in politics
you should tie yourself to the
principles not to a politician you know
not to any show not to any personality
you should tie yourself to principles
and so when I go on my show or when I do
speaking gigs I'm not thinking about a
particular political party I'm thinking
about the principles that I'm fighting
for and so if you can convince me why my
principles are wrong if you can convince
me my way religion is wrong I'm open to
hearing your argument but I've I've
thought through my positions pretty
closely so I don't know that in a debate
I thought oh yep you're right
I'm wrong so you're a young conservative
woman which means that you've
internalized the patriarchy so what
exactly made you conservative to begin
with well I grew up in a conservative
family my dad's a small business owner
and growing up you know we would work
with him at his store and we would see
how businesses run he was very open with
us about his finances taxes government
regulations how that impacted his
business so I think it's a little bit
difficult to experience that in real
life and not come out on the other side
somewhat conservative believing that the
individual knows better than the
government does because you know you can
see for yourself what happens when
government tries to tell somebody what
to do but then you get to a certain
point this is the same with religious
beliefs you get to a certain point where
you're not just drafting on what your
parents believe anymore you have to have
that you know come to Jesus moment where
where you realize your views for
yourself and mine was kind of I don't
want to be told by somebody else want to
do what to do I want to make my own
decisions even if that leads to mistakes
I want to be able to achieve my
potential in the way that I see fit
handle my money the way that I see fit
handle my religion the way that I see
fit exercise my constitutional rights
the way I see fit not the way somebody
some bureaucrat in Washington DC wants
me to live my life and so when you come
to that point you realize of the two
parties the major political party is
only one of the
is offering that opportunity the other
one wants to tell you exactly what you
should be doing and what you're not
allowed to do so what are the
shortcomings with the Republican Party
because you talk about their the
differences between the Republican and
Democratic Party I think in theory
that's true in practice it seems to be a
lot less true considering the size and
scope of government that even the
Republican Party is pushing these days
right well the number one problem with
the Republican Party right now is
spending I mean we're support
conservatives are supposed to be
fiscally conservative we're not supposed
to spend like the Democrats spend and we
can see I mean it's not just this
administration it's Congress Republicans
in Congress
it's the Pryor Republican administration
President Bush spent like crazy nobody
has the appetite anymore to make the
pitch to voters why we need fiscal
conservatism I tell people watching my
show all the time this is why it's so
dangerous when Democrats offer free
stuff to voters as a way to sort of buy
their votes because once you've made
that offer once you have bought them off
it's very difficult for somebody else to
come in and say actually I'd like your
vote and my platform is I'm gonna take
away your free stuff nobody really is
gonna buy into that and when we have
politicians whose interest is keeping
their seat for as long as possible
versus serving the interests of our
Constitution and their constituents
they're not going to make an argument
that they know right off the bat is a
losing argument so do you think that
we're basically screwed when it comes to
spending because that obviously holds
true for Republicans as well as
Democrats and Trump in 2016 openly
campaigned on not changing the
entitlement programs that are destroying
our budget and represent 66% of all
spending all of it mandatory in the
United States we have to change it or
else we're going to be on the road to
Greece there's no there's no two ways
about it if we don't stop spending we're
going to run out of money to spend and
then we are going to default somebody
and I think this is more incumbent even
on Republicans in Congress than
president Trump he can certainly
advocate for that but it's congressional
Republicans who have to do the hard work
they have to be the ones who put those
tough spending proposals and actually
make plans to implement fiscal
conservatism and yes that includes
reforming these entitlements that so
many people want to believe are
untouchable they're going to be
untouchable in less than 10 years if we
don't do something they're going to be
untouchable
we're not have any money to spend in
them so to go back for a second to hear
your personal story so you talked about
why you're conservative but what got you
into politics in the first place because
a lot of people have conservative
parents and don't end up doing what you
do for a living
Barack Obama dead in 2007 that was some
kind of the first time I paid attention
to politics on my own versus just you
know seeing it in my sphere or seeing my
parents pay attention to it I started
following the Democratic primary
watching him compete with Hillary
Clinton in the day that he won the
election I thought to myself you know
this man really does want to
fundamentally transform America away
from what has made America so great and
I you know I would see these politicians
on the debate stage Republican
politicians saying the wrong things you
know they're not they're not speaking to
what voters have the capacity to here
they're not packaging limited government
and conservative principles in a way
that's palatable to basically anybody
outside of Washington DC and I thought
to myself I can say these things better
than these politicians I can tell people
why conservative principles are the best
for them and for their family and for
our nation and so I thought to myself
then you should do it okay so what do
you think is the specific angle that you
take that a lot of politicians don't
so I've critiqued for a long time the
sort of accounting methodology that that
former Speaker of the House Paul Ryan
was famous for he kind of sit down with
the briefcase and then explain to people
why entitlement spending was bad I've
been very critical of that approach I
think that it is counterproductive but
what do you think is the best approach
when you're trying to convince people
not just debate with people but convince
people who may be undecided about these
issues well you need to think about how
they hear things I mean this is true in
interpersonal relationships too which is
why in one of my chapters of my book
when I give a reading list I actually
give a recommendation for people to read
a couple of books that are about how men
and women relate to each other
because you have to understand human
nature in order to communicate with
people that you don't know they're
outside of your social circle and I
think politicians don't think about the
perspective of the people that they want
to vote for them they're thinking only
about their arguments on the House floor
they're thinking only about their policy
positions what's smart and what's not
smart to them and they're not thinking
about what touches the heart of of one
of their constituents and I'm not
advocating to go just to emotion like
the Democrats do but you also have to be
a relatable individual you have to
listen to what the other purse
and cares about and then you have to
explain why conservative policies best
address what they care about because
hands down I mean I cannot think of an
issue that an individual American cares
about that is not best addressed by
limited government versus big government
okay so let's talk for a second about
the female aspect of what you do meaning
that there's all these there's all of
these opinions out there about what
women are allowed to speak about versus
what men are allowed to speak about this
particularly comes true in the area of
abortion where men are routinely told
that they have to sit down and shut up
because if you are not pro-abortion then
this is obviously because you're not a
woman you're a woman you're obviously
very pro-life so why do you think that
this meme has spread so far and so wide
that women are uniquely pro-abortion
have a unique stake in abortion and that
men should sit down and shut up well men
are told to sit down and shut up because
feminists are scared of there being a
coalition of people regardless of your
gender who are actually pro-life they
are trying to silence as many people as
possible because they're going to lose
the argument on abortion if they
actually had the courage to have the
debate they would lose that 100 out of
100 times and so they tell me as a
conservative woman that I'm not a real
woman because I'm not Pro Borst and they
tell you as a man that you're not
allowed to talk about this because you
don't have a uterus so no uterus no
opinion they are trying to silence as
many people as possible so that the only
people left who are quote unquote
allowed to talk are pro-abortion
feminists so in a second we're gonna get
to the intellectual incoherence of
suggesting that I am NOT a woman so I
can't speak about abortion because I
don't have a uterus but also you don't
need a uterus to be a woman you can
actually just be a biological male but I
want to ask you what you think are the
most convincing arguments in favor of
the pro-life position because there's
the the moral argument that's made
there's the scientific argument that's
made what are you what do you think has
been the most effective moved by
pro-life advocates or change so there's
actually really interesting new
information about this from the
University of Chicago there's a PhD
student he actually just graduated who
did a study on what convinces people to
be pro-life versus pro-abortion and the
number one deciding factor people said
is when does life begin you talk about
this all the time I talk about this all
the time but he said it's the science of
the thing that convinces people and
people want to know when life begins and
so he studied well who when they tell
you when life be
do you give the most credibility to
because sometimes when I say it people
will say you're just saying that because
you're a conservative if you're just
saying that because you're pro-life and
he found that biologists people think
biologists are have the most credibility
when it comes to this argument and then
he did a third step he did a study from
by of biologists all around the world
asking them when life begins and they
responded almost unanimously with life
begins at conception scientifically and
I say almost unanimously because I
believe it was above 95 percent in the
remaining few percent just sent him hate
emails about trying to spew his pro-life
agenda so I mean I think that's the best
way to go about it
of course you can speak to somebody's
religion if they come to you with a
religious issue of course you can speak
to the ethics of the thing but
truthfully the heart of the matter when
it comes to abortion is always when does
life begin and if life begins at
conception which science tells us it
does then what right do we have to end
that human life okay so let's talk for a
second about some of the counter
arguments that I've heard and I'm sure
you've heard on the abortion issue so
one of the counter arguments that I hear
very often is the the bodily autonomy
argument which is sure it's a human life
but it exists inside you you still have
bodily autonomy and so why exactly
should you be forced to bear this child
to term if you're in control of your own
body particularly anything inside of it
right well that comes back I mean what I
tell people in my book when you're
talking about abortion you always want
to bring it back to the heart of the
matter because all of these extraneous
arguments are rendered moot essentially
when you get to the heart of the matter
so you want to talk about bodily
autonomy then you say okay well are we
dealing with one body are we dealing
with two bodies and if they say one body
the woman's then you say well then what
is that what is that that she's pregnant
with what is in her uterus right now
what is in her womb the answer to that
of course is a unique person with unique
set of DNA and it brings it back to that
question when does life begin and if it
begins at conception what right do we
have every single abortion argument can
be brought back to that question and
that's what I encourage people I
advocate for people to bring it back to
that because it's it's kind of a
lose-lose for the pro-abortion crowd if
they don't acknowledge that science says
that life begins at conception then
they're being anti science which is what
they accuse you and I have being all the
time if they do say life begins
and then they're you know undermining
their own argument they're saying well
even though this is another human life I
want the government to say which life
has more value in which life were
allowed to just discard and kill then
just a clarify you're pro-life position
in case of rape and incest you're also
pro-life or you believe there should be
choice available I am really okay so
that that is logically consistent I'm on
the same page obviously the
counter-argument that usually here is
the so-called famous violinist case I'm
sure you've heard this one before yes
from the 1970s very famous philosophy
paper and it basically suggests okay so
you wake up in a room and next to you is
a famous violinist who's been hooked
into your veins and do you have an
obligation not to unhook this famous
violinist if this famous violinist is
going to die absent the IV well you know
the argument there of course is that
like a rape or incest case in that
particular case you didn't will this
person to be connected with you in case
of consensual sex obviously one of the
risks of consensual sex is that you will
indeed get pregnant but if you had no
choice in the matter then it looks a
little bit more like this particular
case how do you take down that
particular argument I mean I think that
conservatives do this very well and
extend a tremendous amount of compassion
to victims of rape and incest in fact I
don't know that there's any demographic
of people in our country who are more
compassionate now I'm not just talking
about on the airwaves I'm talking about
with their money I'm talking about with
their charity to victims of rape and
incest as we should be and we need to
remind people when they're trying to tie
the entire issue of abortion to rape and
incest that rape and incest account for
less than one percent of abortions in
our nation so if we're making abortion
legislation based on rape and incest
then it should only apply to those two
or two that less than one percent of
abortions it should not apply to the
other 99 percent so when when the left
gives me straw Mans
I bring it back to the heart of the
matter every single time because they
don't want to have that conversation I
mean Planned Parenthood we've invited
Planned Parenthood and other abortion
advocacy groups onto my show to debate
me I'm very respectful when I debate
numerous times probably innumerable
times nobody wants to have that debate
they do not want to talk about the heart
of the matter they just want to go off
into the purr
free because they know they're going to
lose I don't let them go off into the
into the periphery so let's talk about
another hot-button issue that you've
talked about a lot and gotten a lot of
flack for and that is the issue of
transgenderism gender identity disorder
gender dysphoria so the right has gotten
a lot of flack again in the the numbers
here tend to break down along the along
gender lines meaning men are less
sympathetic to the arguments with
regards to changing of gender than women
seem to be in the same way that when it
comes to the pro-life pro-choice
argument men tend to be a little bit not
tremendously so a little bit more
pro-life than then women do on
transgender issues it seems like there
actually is a larger gender gap on some
of these issues so where do you stand on
the malleability of gender versus sex
there's something that the left has
forgotten about it's called objective
truth there are two genders male and
female it's coded within our DNA it's
not bigoted to say that it's not
intolerant to say that it's a simple
matter of biology I will never let the
left shut me up from saying that because
it is the truth no matter what they say
again conservatives should offer a
tremendous amount of compassion to
people suffering from gender dysphoria
because they deserve our compassion that
must be an incredible burden to feel
that you are trapped in the wrong body
to feel that you are a different gender
that's a legitimate psychiatric disorder
and we should treat these people with
dignity and respect and love but
treating them with dignity and respect
and love is not allowing them to be used
as political pawns for the left's
political agenda and that's what the
left is doing they are trying to exploit
these people under the guise of saying
they're tolerant under the guise of
saying they're trying that you know
we're trying to include transgender
people in polite society the left is
actually exploiting them and we
shouldn't let them do that because it's
part of their larger scheme if you will
their larger scheme to undermine the
family because when you when you
advocate for transgender ISM meaning
when you do that politically what you're
doing is you're saying that there's no
real gender roles right and if there's
no traditional gender roles and there
can't be any traditional relationships
if there's no traditional relationships
then there can't be a traditional
marriage if there's not a traditional
marriage and there can't be a
traditional family unit if there's not a
traditional family unit then everybody
in our nation is rendered dependent on
the
permit which conservatives identify as
the ultimate goal of many Democratic
politicians they want money and they
want power and to do that they control
the people do you think that it has more
do that the left's agenda on this has
more to do with the interference of
government or does it have more to do
with the general attempts to redefine
terms along subjective lines because it
seems to me that's even a deeper issue
it's the left obviously wants a bigger
government right it seems to me that
what the left really wants more than
anything else along these lines and
virtually all others is to radically
redefine reality in terms of
subjectivity the idea being that we are
supposed to simply respect what you
think of yourself and take that as a
given reality and that any attempt to to
say something that is objectively true
is offensive to you I and and the goal
there is that once we can't even have a
common conversation anymore well then
how are we supposed to how are we
supposed to live together I think that
the the the attempt to break down gender
is is part of an attempt to break down
religion part of an attempt to break
down social institutions not in favor of
government but just in favor of leveling
but I think you have to ask why like why
would they do that just independently
why would they care if there's no such
thing as objective truth if it wasn't in
pursuit of a larger goal because I don't
think that as many leftists and I'm not
lumping together liberal voters with
leftists I said I don't think leftists
do I don't think they impose their
agenda haphazardly I think they do it on
purpose and with a purpose it's one of
the things that I talk about in my book
actually that you have to define it you
have to define what it is that they want
because when you define what it is that
the left wants you can understand that
each of their attacked you know whether
it is on Christianity and religion or
the family or our education system or
whatever it is when they are attacking
these things they're doing it with a
purpose and their purpose is to tear
down in my opinion their purpose is to
tear down these cultural cornerstones so
that people are dependent on government
they're not doing it just for the sake
of doing it maybe some individual is but
collectively I think they're doing it in
order to consolidate control in the
government because that's what benefits
them the most so how much do you think
is malice and how much do you think is
stupidity I guess is the question
because because really it seems like
yeah you're probably right when it comes
to a few thinkers members of
at school people who are actual Marxists
who wish to see institutions collapse
that they can rebuild the new utopian
tomorrow but the vast majority of people
who support for example the transgender
rights movement I don't think that they
have any any such thoughts about this it
seems to me that it really is as deep as
I feel unsympathetic if I don't just say
that people are what they say they are
and thus I'm I don't want to look cruel
I don't want to feel cruel and what does
it hurt me well isn't that what why you
and I do what we do for a living because
there are many people who hear these
things and they feel compassionate as
they should it's a good part of human
nature to see somebody who's oppressed
somebody who's been marginalized and say
hey I want to be on that person side I
want to stand up for them I want them to
be treated with dignity and respect and
so they see they hear this rhetoric from
you know the upper echelons of the
transgender movement and they say listen
I want to be on that side because I want
to stand with it with the marginalized
people and they're not you're right
they're not thinking through why the
transgender movement is doing what they
do but I think absolutely I think it's
directed by special interest by an
ideology that wants to consolidate power
into government because I honestly don't
think that all I don't think that it
would be as concerted of an effort to
morph this politically correct culture
into the laws of our nature of our
nation if they didn't have a larger plan
all right Snowden I ask you about a
couple more issues and then I want to
ask you some sort of broader
philosophical questions so let's talk
for a second about an issue that seems
to be very divisive again along gender
lines and this is the the issue of
immigration and in national security on
the border so men tend to be a lot
harder on border policy than women do
there's been a lot of talk in the media
about lack of sympathy from the Trump
administration for people crossing the
border you are a border hawk what do you
make of this argument um I think this is
a matter of Democrat politicians tell
lies to the American people truthfully I
mean we can I want to talk about the
immigration rules that the Trump
administration just unveiled the ones
about catch and release the one about
detaining children with their families
do you know what this issue is actually
about human trafficking the trafficking
of little children if you're a border
patrol agent or a nice agent you are
giving pregnancy tests to little girls
as young as 11 years old if that does
not break your heart and break your soul
to hear that then I I don't even know
how to talk
and yet the left is not interested in
practical solutions about how to prevent
those children from being trafficked the
number of those children that are being
trafficked increased by 300% I believe
it was last year to the first half of
this year because the catch and release
program because that policy incentivizes
illegal immigrants or illegal aliens who
are claiming asylum incentivizes them to
bring children with them because they
know under the Flores settlement
agreement children can't be detained for
more than 20 days so parents and
children are released with a court date
after that twenty days they fade into
the shadows they never show up for their
court date and voila they're in the
United States for free but what happens
to those children the left you say that
to the left in their head is going to
explode they're not gonna listen to you
about human trafficking they're not
gonna listen to you about the sexual
abuse of women or children at our border
and that should show you all you need to
know about whether the left is arguing
about the border in good faith or not
because if they cared about women and
children the way that they claim that
they do they would be applauding they
would be standing up and giving a
standing ovation to what the Trump
administration just did so one more
issue that I want to get your opinion on
and then we can get into some more broad
philosophy and that is the the crime
issue so it seems like this should be an
area particularly where women really are
conservative I mean and this was the
premise of the 2004 election George W
Bush ran on the so-called security Moms
women who are deeply concerned about
national security and crime and yet
right now what we are watching is
movement by both parties away from sort
of tough on crime tactics including the
Trump administration which signed into
law criminal justice reform and we've
tried that here in California it does
not work particularly well well what's
your take on on how the government
should be dealing with crime I think we
should enforce the laws that we have on
our books I mean that's that's job
number one I mean you can apply this to
any any area of crime I mean we can talk
about how it applies to gun crime but we
have the left telling us that we need
all of this gun control all these new
laws I think they have like 13 proposals
in you know the Parkland kids green new
deal for guns whatever they're calling
it a peace plan all of these different
things if we had just applied the laws
on our books we don't need gun control
to keep us safe so that but that's a
microcosm of our entire criminal justice
system if we actually enforce the laws
in our books
we wouldn't have the same issues that we
have today
wouldn't be such a politically I don't
even want to call it a politically
dismissive topic so much as a
politically dishonest topic people
pretend like they're on one set of
criminal justice or the other just to
get votes but they don't have actually
any intention of enforcing laws that we
do have and so now I want to ask about
the more general question so sure so as
I mentioned before there's this massive
gender gap between men and women
particularly with regard to President
Trump but just true politically
generally it's a growing gender gap it's
getting worse you're making a very
articulate case as a woman for pro-life
positions for pro-pro hawkish positions
on immigration for for pro for
anti-crime positions you know all of
these are convincing arguments with
which I agree so why is it that this
gender gap is widening not not narrowing
I think because of what I said before I
think the Democratic politicians tell
lies all the time the mainstream media
disseminates those lies to all the four
corners of our country not everybody
spends as much time as you and I do
researching every day so I'm not gonna
sit here and castigate people who you
know fall for the propaganda but
essentially essentially that's what's
happening if you're not someone who's
highly plugged into the conservative
movement or conservative media then some
of these arguments that are coming from
the left at surface value at least sound
very compelling I mean think about those
pictures you know we're talking about
immigration think about those pictures
of those little kids those little girls
wrapped in those foil blankets in cages
next to porta-potties you know
surrounded by barbed wire that should
you know that should break our hearts
such that is really sad and if you don't
do your research or if you're not
plugged in you might think that
President Trump was the one who just put
them there and not realize that those
photographs were from 2014 2015 when
President Obama was in office that seems
obvious to you and mean but not
everybody is as plugged in to see those
things so again that's that's why I do
what I do because I want people to have
an avenue to hear the truth I want
people to hear the liberal talking
points and say oh that does sound kind
of convincing and then tune in to me in
my show and hear me say it does sound
convincing if it were true and here's
why it's not true well I mean I think
that answers why so many people are
deceived generally but it to get back to
the sort of gender gap why is it that
more women than men seem to be buying
into left-wing arguments and again I
think the gender gap is a really obvious
thing that's been happening I mean Yaqui
you can see it the Democrats for
the war against the war on women in 2012
with Mitt Romney and then they did the
same thing in 2016 the great danger to
president Trump electoral speaking is
women in the suburbs it is not men per
se it is don't you think it's fearful
because the Democrats that's that's what
I would identify it as because the
Democrats target women especially
suburban women and say listen if you
don't support radical leftist policies
then you're gonna be relegated back to
you know what many women consider to be
their worst nightmare you know not able
to vote not able to drive not able to
have a job not able necessarily to
choose who they want to marry or where
they're able to live you know sort of
the proverbial and I don't mean any
disrespect to my grandparents generation
but the proverbial you know 30s 40s 50s
housewife that is just cleaning house
and cooking and I don't mean any
disrespect to people who do that but
there's a difference between doing that
when you choose to do that and do that
and doing that when you're forced to do
that and so the Democrats have made a
concerted effort ever since the sexual
revolution to put fear in the hearts of
women to scare women into supporting
their policies because otherwise you
women you're gonna be oppressed by the
patriarchy you're gonna be put back into
the dark ages and you're not gonna have
any freedom in men they're strong enough
to keep you to keep you marginalized
well this does bring us to the question
of President Trump and what you saw in
2016 you'll start there what why do you
think President Trump
ends up loading the election of 2016
because obviously he was expected to
lose by everyone including President
Trump I think he won because he's not
afraid to push back on the radical
leftist ideology on the narrative that's
being perpetuated by the mainstream
media I mean conservatives who followed
along not just this election not just
the Obama administration but even going
back to george w bush conservatives all
over the country were so frustrated when
you know bush and his administration
didn't push back against the media that
really I think was red meat to the
mainstream media you know they saw what
they could get away with and a lot of
people across the country were really
fed up with that because propaganda does
work so when the media is engaging in
this propaganda it does make a
difference in how many people vote if
they're not as engaged as you and I are
and President Trump isn't afraid to just
point at someone and say that is BS that
is ridiculous
don't try any of this nonsense on me
don't try to castigate
life views or immigration views or free
market views as being racist or bigoted
or homophobic that's not true he's not
afraid to fight no matter how hard they
fight back and I think that appealed to
a lot of people me included our country
but that's at where do you think 2020 is
going to go given given the prevailing
trends I saw a I had a very interesting
conversation with a professor from
American University named Allan Lichtman
on my show this week
he has predicted the past nine
presidential elections correctly based
on an algorithm that he devised it's not
based on the polls he has 13 elements in
his algorithm and he says a sitting
president must lose six of those
elements in order to lose reelection and
he says president Trump has only lost
three I find that to be the most
convincing argument because I don't buy
into polls and I don't buy into
predictions 18 months before a
presidential election well I mean I
think that it's smart not to buy into
polls 18 months or it's as it turns out
18 hours before a presidential election
I lost a lot of money in the last
presidential election betting as the
data went and that was a horrible
horrible mistake but with that said do
you have fears that the President Trump
is vulnerable I mean if you had let's
say you were the odds maker and you had
nobody should ever take their position
for granted voters should always go out
and vote you should never feel
comfortable in your position that's
that's the easiest way to not be taken
advantage of but that's the easiest way
to lose your seat and be surprised about
it President Trump should campaign on
what he's done he should campaign on
what he's still going to do voters
should go out and vote they should look
at his record especially voters who
during the 2016 campaign didn't believe
that he was going to be conservative on
anything they should look at what he's
accomplished and they should see that no
spending is still out of control but the
vast majority of things is it's
absolutely incredible resume of
conservative achievements and so they
should decide well which which direction
do I want our country to go in and if
you want our country to go in the
direction of conservatism well then
there's one obvious choice and you
should go out and you should vote that
choice so as I've been saying for years
President Trump appears to be a hammer
and he's a hammer in search of a nail
sometimes gets a nail squarely and it's
really satisfying and sometimes it's a
baby and it's not nearly as satisfying
so with that said let's say that you're
advising Trump what do you advise him to
do in terms of how he approaches things
publicly do you think that he just
continues to do it he's doing he just
let Trump be Trump or do you think that
Trump should tone it down on to
do you think that he should maybe speak
a little bit less wildly a little bit
more advised in fashion what would you
recommend you want my honest opinion
sure I actually think Trump's tweets are
awesome not a hundred percent of them
but more often than not they make me
laugh they're true they might be harsh
and they get the media to talk about
what he wants them to talk about he the
media doesn't even realize 99% of the
time that he is trolling them that he is
actually not the producers in their
Studios he is actually dictating what
they're going to talk about all day long
they don't realize that and I I you know
I sit back and I watch these tweets come
in on my phone all the time as as we all
do and honestly I think I think they're
awesome I think that's one of the
reasons why he won not not every tweet
there's some you know as we all do that
I say well should have phrased that
different or once in a while there'll be
a cringe but most the time I think
they're awesome
so you're a big believer in president
Trump's tweets I guess listen yeah as a
member as members of his base are
constantly telling me his tweets are
unbelievable
I enjoyed my fair share of President
Trump's tweets sometimes I find them
absolutely hilarious because he's very
underappreciated as being hilarious he's
very very funny I mean it is it is one
of the chief things about him that is
appealing is that he's basically a
stand-up comedian being the president I
mean all of his rallies this is what the
media don't understand about him is that
when he doesn't rally he's not scripting
like Obama
he's not even scripting like W he's out
there riffing like Dennis Miller would
at a live standup yeah and and that
that's exactly what it is and that's why
when people like why don't people take
seriously Woody's because he's not
taking himself seriously at these
rallies we push back on this remember
what I said before about the mistake
that politicians make the mistake that
politicians make is they don't think
about how their audience is hearing
something right
so what President Trump does is he
always thinks about what how his
audience is hearing him what they want
to hear yes but he's always thinking
about how they're going to respond to it
that's how he has that connection with
with them and that's what sets him apart
from most other politicians that's not a
bad thing in a politician I mean it's a
good thing in front of a live audience I
will object to the phrase always thinks
in connection with President Trump just
as a general matter but when President
Trump is in front of a live audience I
mean he is performing in front of a live
audience you're a performer I'm a
performer in front of a live audience
you have a symbiotic relationship with
the audience and Trump does that as well
as anybody the problem is there's a
whole
camera crew there and there they're
projecting this to hundreds of millions
of people and he let me present the
counter-argument to the Trump's to each
have the greatest thing and I'm gonna
get him reelected okay okay here we go
that might be a little bit of a
hyperbolic it I don't mean I don't mean
it's wrong I don't mean to try anything
but the will say that you like his
tweets and you did good there i positive
okay so let so here is the case against
there's a mythology that's been built up
around 2016 the mythology goes something
like this
hillary clinton was a wonderful or at
least mediocre candidate president Trump
ran in a fantastically different
campaign that mobilized an entire group
of people who hadn't gone to the polls
before and he won a sweeping victory
because of that I don't think that's
true I think what happened is that
people looked at Hillary Clinton and
they didn't go out to vote for her
because they thought number one she was
definitely going to win so they just
didn't show up to the polls and number
two they just weren't all that enthused
about her so they didn't show up
figuring she was gonna win okay so if
you were like lukewarm on her and you
don't like Trump all that much I think
all right fine maybe I'll show up for
her maybe I won't it's raining outside
forget it not gonna happen and then
people just didn't show up for her in
the key battleground state she wins the
popular vote by two point five million
and she loses in the narrowest gauntlet
in American history she loses Ohio
pretty solidly but then she loses
Michigan Pennsylvania in Wisconsin all
very narrowly now the proof of my
position that this was about Hillary
losing and not about Trump winning and
mobilizing that vast new movement is
that Trump actually one fewer absolute
votes in Wisconsin than Mitt Romney did
and Mitt Romney lost the state
overwhelmingly to Barack Obama and
Donald Trump won the state of Wisconsin
that's not about Trump mobilizing voters
Romney didn't that's about Hillary
Clinton failing to mobilize the voters
that Barack Obama did because Barack
Obama was the actual statistical outlier
and this holds true in nearly every
state Donald Trump performed like
Generic Republican the dirty little
secret is he didn't perform like non
generic Republican he actually performed
within margin of error in nearly every
state with Mitt Romney and George W Bush
in every single state well the problem
there is that it was a referendum on
Hillary Clinton now we move forward to
2020 there's no longer referendum on
Hillary Clinton now it's a referendum on
Donald Trump because he's the President
of the United States
so as I've been saying if the referendum
is on Elizabeth Warren and her garbage
ideas no but it's not Trump wins if it's
a referendum on Trump and him as a
personality then he's got a real problem
it was just a referendum on the economy
well then we'll have to see where the
economy is in about 18 months because I
think everyone agrees that if the
economy takes any sort of dump at all
he's
right but you're missing a big point
here the point is that this is a
referendum and Trump has made it this
through his tweets on the leftist
ideology it's the mainstream media that
he is battling here because the
mainstream media has been the PR firm of
the Democratic Party so yes he's not
running against Hillary Clinton anymore
he's now running on his own record sure
most people are doing better than they
were before
Trump was president so he's good there
but I don't his tweets have also changed
by the way from during the election in
2016 so now he's ramp them up they're
more bombastic even they're certainly
more frequent he targets people much
more specifically but here's why and I'm
gonna reference actually an article that
you wrote I believe it was last week you
said what would this week look like in
conservative achievements if something
hadn't we'd yes this is right if Trump
hadn't tweeted and I think it's a good
point but I would push back and say to
the left nothing is ever good enough
unless you fully adhere to the radical
leftist ideology this is the canceled
culture that we talk about in society
all the time so it doesn't matter that
Trump is Trump they call him a racist
and a white supremacist and evil because
he's a Republican not because he is
racist or white supremacists are evil
and you can look at proof of that when
you look at how the media handled you
know a sort of lukewarm Republican like
Mitt Romney
they said he was evil - he wasn't
tweeting they're gonna treat a
Republican exactly the same no matter
how they are no matter whether that
Republican is tweeting or not because
that person is a Republican Trump
shouldn't in my opinion cede any ground
to them and say oh you want me to act a
certain way I'll act a certain way
because you want it because they're just
gonna push further I think about seating
around of the media I mean that that is
my favorite part of what Trump does I
mean when he when he's lashing out at
CNN I have virtually no problem I think
they may bear garbage I think them
garbage of their job forever I don't
think he's the first person to do it by
the way I think that Newt Gingrich did
it in 2012 in the primaries and it's why
Newt had that brief moment of glory when
he started ripping on John Harwood in
the middle of a debate right so I mean
this is this is not something new Trump
has just made it into an art form
but the the problem is that the art of
politics is making it very difficult for
people to vote for your opponent and
making it a lot easier for people to
vote for you Trump makes it very
difficult for people to vote for his
opponent and also makes it very
difficult for people to vote for him
specifically because of this and the
proof concept here is not 2016 it's 2018
meaning if you watch 2018 for a brief
moment in time
a referendum on democrats during the
Cavanagh hearings before the Kavanagh
hearings the democrats were up in the
generic ballot somewhere between 8 and
10 points
the Cavanaugh hearings happened and
suddenly Komal Harris is in our faces
and suddenly you see all the Democrats
making complete fools of themselves
pushing against due process suggesting
that people can be railroaded with
thirty-year-old allegations that have no
evidence to back them and the American
people get annoyed and suddenly the
polls close up and and it's basically a
dead heat going into the election then
the Cavanaugh hearings end and president
Trump says you know what I got to ramp
up my base I'm gonna talk you legal
immigration for the next three weeks and
I'm gonna go out I'm in a rally and I'm
gonna tweet about illegal immigration
for the next three weeks and suddenly
people's minds shift from I really don't
want Kamala Harris in charge of the
country and her and her folks in charge
of the country Democrats in charge of
the country and it shifts to oh god he's
tweeting again oh god he's just saying
things and they're thinking about that
when they go into the polling places
particularly in purple areas with
suburban women and they've not only vote
against him they they vote against
Republicans overwhelmingly that is not
that that was a that was a wave election
we like to call it not a way of election
it was a way of election by the
statistics it did not have to be a way
of election if President Trump had been
quiet after the Cavanagh hearings or
just said the word Cavanaugh 1 million
times before the end of the Cavanaugh
hearings in the election I understand
what you're saying in in one sense but
that's a certain time in history I mean
this is this is a you know this is
another time in history already just
another year and I think you have we
have to ask ourselves well what is the
approval rating among Republicans of
President Trump and how does that
compare to past incumbent Republicans
who are facing reelection I think the
number is 94 percent of Republicans
approve a president Trump that's
astronomical comparatively to other
presidents in our history so most of
those people are most likely going to
turn out and vote yes his base will show
up no question question is there is a
poll number that I saw and I know you
were not supposed to respect poll
numbers but but if if people don't like
either candidate so in 2016 there's a
poll showed that there are a bunch of
polls that showed if you don't like
either Trump or Hillary you're actually
more likely to vote for Trump if you
don't like their polls now that show
that if you don't like for example Trump
or Biden you're more likely to vote for
Biden by I think a factor of 3 in other
words Trump may be alienating exactly
the people that he needs to not yeah the
the Rust Belt
the suburban women I mean Texas there
there's a reason that for Republican
Congress people have bowed out there's a
reason the Texas is trending purple for
all the talk about Trump being a
glorious victorious winner the fact is
the MIT Romney won the state by 12 Texas
about immigration and the Democrat
exchanging in that in that state and
people from California moving to Texas
and all those different things
domestically domestically born Texans
are voting blue in larger numbers than
California and expatriate so in our
state for a lot but we can save it for
that but it's also the demographic
change not just of Californians moving
there but of Latinos who are you know
crossing the border and settling in
Texas and raising their kids there and
changing the demographics from while
governments the Trump Trump wildly
underperforms of Latinos in Texas in a
way that for example Greg Abbott does
not or Ted Cruz does not I mean the fact
is you're right demographics are
changing in Texas but let's put this way
from loses Texas elections over I think
we all agree this I don't think that he
is going to lose Texas I think he'll win
Texas but I think that it'll be narrow
right now it is very narrow in Arizona
it's very narrow in in New Hampshire
there are there a lot of states he's
doing well in the states that are
heavily rural right he's gonna do well
in Iowa probably held zhuge well in Ohio
presumably but in a lot of the states
where the movement has been toward urban
areas and away from rural areas if
Republicans don't find a way to win
those elections then they're not going
to be in office I guess my question
would be I agree but this this trend has
been a trend it didn't start under
President Trump so I guess my question
would be if if you're laying the blame
at the feet of President Trump what's
the baby totally what's the basis of
that because this is a trend that
started I mean the turn Texas blue
movement whatever they call themselves
that's long before Trump ever came down
that elevator that's true and then Wendy
Davis got her ass kicked I mean the fact
is that does Trump exacerbate the wrong
kinds of trends or does he alleviate the
wrong kinds of trends and this is really
a question for Ken Trump to better right
I mean this is not me trying to say that
President Trump is definitely gonna lose
but I want him to lose god forbid I
don't want Elizabeth Warren to be
President stated before her show but if
Trump could contain himself wouldn't
that be a better strategy than simply
his base roaring him all the way to I
think there's a third option there I
think so I does respond to this actually
briefly before before we went on air but
I think there's a third option a way
that President Trump can win Democrat
voters without without stopping what
doing without changing who he is without
you know curbing his tweets without
stopping implementing conservative
policies and it's probably the least
sexy sounding political issue out there
but school choice if he talks about
school choice if he pushes school choice
champions for charter schools and school
vouchers then there are going to be
Democrat voters whose children go to
those schools minority moms whose
children go to those schools they're
registered Democrats but they want the
best for their kids and I think that
that's a secret weapon that President
Trump can use to expand his base in some
of these states we saw this this isn't a
hypothetical opinion we saw this happen
in Florida in 2018 when DeSantis now
governor DeSantis a Republican defeated
Andrew Gilliam he did so by a margin of
just 32 thousand votes right but a
hundred thousand African American women
registered Democrats whose kids went to
charter schools voted for DeSantis at
the same time they voted for the
Democrat Senator Bill Nelson and they
did that because the Santos was
promising to champion charter schools
and Andrew Gilliam was promising you
know to abolish let me call them a
siphon on the public school system so
even though this doesn't sound like an
issue that's exciting it doesn't sound
like a bombastic tweet it doesn't sound
like a media narrative when you're
talking to actual voters about what
matters to them going back to what I
said earlier I think this is a way that
President Trump can compliment what he's
doing now compliment what appeals to his
base and also reach across the aisle to
a demographic that's not served by their
Democrat representatives who are
actually told by their Democrat
representatives that's what what is best
for them and their family and their
children and their children's education
is not what the government wants them to
be doing if he does that I actually
think that would be a secret weapon that
would help them win a lot of Democrat
votes I mean I would love to see him do
that I'd love to see make the tax cuts
permanent as well it's been kind of
fascinating since the Democrats took
over the house he hasn't really issued a
lot of calls for legislation
aside from school choice why would you
like to see him push the Democrats on
spending I'd like to see that especially
in a second term when you're not up
against reelection I think we need to do
that I would if I were the president I
would veto any budget that came on my
desk that didn't defund Planned
Parenthood I think you want to get you
want to get your base excited you want
to get you know your religious space you
want to get your pro-life female base
excited you defund Planned Parenthood
tax cuts are always good his red
in push I mean one of the things that I
think is the most underappreciated thing
that he has done it's becoming a little
more appreciated now is his appointment
of federal judges he is remaking the
federal judiciary and that is a legacy
that will last much longer than any term
a president can ever hold these judges
that Trump is appointing are
constitutionally minded folks they are
going to not be judicial activists
they're not going to bend with the winds
of politics they're going to uphold
constitutional values which puts a you
know a block add or block in the way of
what the radical left is trying to do
which is codify politically correct
culture into law not legislatively but
through our courts so a strategic
question not just for President Trump
but for all Republicans right now there
there's a real incentive on the part of
people on the right to not pick to look
at the left and find the nuttiest ideas
and point those out because they are
plentiful it is especially because again
then nuts may have actually taken over
the party at this point but there is a
danger in doing what so many of us have
done and that is elevating the most
extreme elements in the Democratic Party
I understand that the party has moved in
very extreme directions but elevating
the most extreme members of the
Democratic Party at the expense of some
of the not quite as extreme but still
extreme members of the Democratic Party
on the one hand it makes it obvious to
the American public how extreme and
radical the Democrats are on the other
hand we may be embolden in the people
who end up governing us and that
frightens me a little bit I mean are you
worried about that because the Democrats
basically did do this with Donald Trump
in 2016 they kept saying well you know
who we'd love to run against would be
that Trump guy because he's nuts
and then Trump becomes president of
course and he governs in extraordinarily
conservative fashion should we be more
careful about the opponents that we
select should we be trying to put our
thumbs on the scale in favor of
Democrats who are slightly more
reasonable than for example the squad or
should we be rooting for the squad to
take over leadership of the Democratic
Party um I would respond to that by
asking who's more reasonable in the
Democratic Party
who's the reasonable one they're they're
a couple of Blue Dog Democrats left in
Virginia I mean we could we could root
for them I was rooting for now what was
that the one who just one day brassy it
is a slightly more exactly though nobody
even knows who they are right I mean
they break the one guy
we're in the Midwest but even even Nancy
Pelosi books moderate next to these
clowns right she's not I mean three
years ago we thought she was the most
radically left that any politician the
craziest any politician could get and
then it turns out behind door number
three exactly so I I don't know I don't
know if we're particularly elevating it
or if the Democratic Party has been
elevating it I mean I think this was the
result of Bernie Sanders running against
Hillary Clinton in 2016 he certainly
lost but the impact his legacy is that
he moved the Democratic Party from just
being liberal and left maybe even what I
would consider far left under Barack
Obama to being radically socialist
leftist ideology the just as far left as
you can possibly go they're advocating
outright there saying socialism is a
good thing they want cultural Marxism
they want essentially communism I mean
we didn't make them take these policy
positions we are just saying that policy
position that you're taking it's
dangerous and stupid and here's why
we're going to debunk it so that nobody
falls for it so let's talk about the
2020 Democratic side of the aisle so
right now as we currently sit here Joe
Biden is collapsing in on himself like a
dying star apparently according to the
polls Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders both running in tandem near
where Joe Biden is there are a couple of
polls in the last week that basically
have Biden receding back to the rest of
the field not a great shot considering
that he was a weak candidate going in
how do you see this race going the rest
of the way and who do you think the
nominee is oh I hesitate to make
predictions a year and a half out I
think it depends on what people say how
bad of gas Joe Biden makes whether
people care about looking at Elizabeth
Warren's actual policies I know she's
kind of getting this cultural meme
status for always having a plan for
everything and in a sense kudos you know
having a plan don't just run on a
talking point notice Ellen but sure yeah
exactly but if you look at if you look
at her actual plans they're terrifying
and so I talked about this on my show
all the time I don't just want to talk
about Elizabeth Warren's cultural
appropriation pretend Cherokee heritage
I mean it's bad by leftist standards but
if you look at some of the other things
that she stands forming the accountable
capitalism Act if Elizabeth Warren gets
the nomination and I'm Trump that's what
I talk about the accountable capitalism
Act empowers the government the federal
government to expropriate any private
business in our nation that earns more
than 1 billion dollars in revenue that's
something like 3,500 private businesses
that Elizabeth Warren wants to be
the purview of the government and not
the people they have to obtain a federal
Charter meaning permission from the
government to run their business and a
set of standards about how they want to
run their business or else the
government comes in and fully takes it
over
that is literally socialism so you mean
you talk about some of these things or
president Trump and all Republicans
running should talk about the details of
these peoples policies because those
middle voters that 30% who voted for
Obama first and then voted for Trump in
2016 they don't like that sort of thing
that's too radical for them and that
would either keep them from voting for
an Elizabeth Warren or drive them to
vote for President Trump so on a
personal level change topics really ugly
have you been dealing with the added
notoriety of what you do so obviously
you know five six years ago some people
knew you now a lot more people know you
have you dealt with the the blowback
that you've received for doing what it
is that you do you've obviously become
one of the more hated figures on welcome
to the club enjoy it's a party out here
but have you been dealing with that on a
personal level um I'm really fortunate
to have a support system a really strong
family support system a really strong
group of friends you know my husband is
an incredible support we were together
long before I had a show on one American
it's really I found it very beneficial
to be around people who were my friends
were my family were my support before I
was ever on television because those
people you know they just they just look
at me for me not for me on television
and so when you're surrounded by that
when you're fortunate enough are blessed
enough to have that support system I
think it's a lot easier to let that
stuff roll off your back I'm not a
terribly thin skinned person to begin
with I mostly look at insults that are
hurled at me in a positive way meaning I
don't enjoy I'm human I don't enjoy
being insulted but if the left doesn't
have an argument back a counterpoint to
what I say then they resort to ad
hominem so that means that I won that
point right so if you kind of look at
insult that way and then don't look at
insults if it starts to get to you don't
look at your timeline if you know you're
getting piled on by a bunch of people
who aren't wanting to argue policy
they're just wanting to insult you
personally don't look at it go hang out
with your family go hang out with your
friends go read a book go live your life
outside of politics and you know let
people waste their time insulting you if
that's what they want to do have you
gotten really good at that
working on that for years the looking at
the notifications any tips on that like
seriously just don't do it yeah that's
basically have started to do that it
basically gone turkey on some put your
phone down we both know this I think
we're both Twitter addicts but I don't
know I my rule is just if something
starts to get to me if I see an insult
and I'm and it actually hurts my
feelings and I'm like okay it's time to
step away because you know that
shouldn't hurt your feelings that
shouldn't be something that makes you
think anything differently about
yourself or something that makes you
feel insecure so if there's anything
that does I step away um much of the
time it doesn't because you know it just
I Know Who I am
I know that I'm a child of God I know
that I'm loved I know that I'm beautiful
I know that you know that I have so much
to bring to the world I'm not insecure
when someone calls me a profane name
because I know that that's not true I
know that that comes from a place of
ignorance of stupidity of probably hurts
within themselves it just doesn't change
my view of myself so you know we talked
a little bit earlier about the idea of
being a conversation and shifting you
know on fundamental principle I agree
with you that if you're really studied
in your own fundamental principles the
changes that are gonna be minor in a
rare yeah I've never been changed on a
question of policy yeah a specific
question of policy yeah the death
penalty I used to be very Pro death
penalty you know if a you get these
terrible criminals why not you know they
deserve to die right that's just that's
just justice and I have shifted on that
probably not a hundred percent
anti-death-penalty but you look at the
statistics of how many errors there are
how many people are executed and their
DNA afterward exonerates them and that's
inexcusable and our justice system that
we cannot tolerate that especially in an
era where these the most terrible
criminals don't have the possibility of
escaping you know it might have been
different back in the Wild West where
people could escape prison you know to
actually to actually keep them from
harming other people you had to put them
to death for example but that's not the
case anymore we can keep people from
harming other people without putting
them to death and the purpose of our
justice system I think philosophically
is not to engage in revenge it's not
vengeance
we're not supposed to play God the
purpose of our justice system is to
restore order to our society and
we have to unfortunately tragically we
have to remove some people from society
we have to incarcerate some people when
they have violated other people's rights
and can't be trusted not to violate
people's rights again but that's the
extent to which our justice system
should go we shouldn't be saying what
these people deserve or what you know
what we think they ought to get because
of what they do we just have to protect
people and as human nature I think it's
hard to do that when you see some of the
most egregious crimes committed by the
most evil of people but yeah that's one
that I've changed my thinking on so on a
burner leveled how does religion play in
your life or your religious person yes I
am I'm a practicing Catholic is
everything of Who I am so maybe you can
talk a little bit about that how does
that how does that play in your politics
um it plays into my politics well I mean
kind of what I just said before about
it's my identity I'm a child of Christ I
Know Who I am I know that I am loved I
know I am created fearfully and
wonderfully made I know that I am put on
this earth for a purpose I know that my
role on this earth is to further the
kingdom of God to love other people as
Christ loves me I try to do that through
my politics as well I think you know God
gave us free will he didn't make us the
same as animals he wants us to have a
choice between good and evil so that we
can choose him so that our choice is of
free will to choose him and I think
conservative policies allow people not
only to achieve the potential that our
Creator put within them to achieve but
also to make those choices in their own
lives between good and evil it's also
the most compassionate we're called I
think any religious tradition calls us
to be generous and loving and charitable
to other people and conservative
principles allow us to do that better
than any other form of government that
the world has ever known so well we've
talked a lot about arguing politics how
do you go about arguing or discussing
religion with people or do you sort of
try to stay away from it because people
tend to have their own private beliefs
um all right we don't talk I don't have
a lot of political or religious
arguments on air I always say that my
political arguments are based on both
you know secular practicality combined
with the morality that my faith informs
so I never add
vacate for a political policy based just
on my religion I'm never gonna say oh
the government should force everybody to
go to confession once a week because
otherwise you know you're going to be in
you know you're going to have committed
a mortal sin obviously that should be
your choice whether to do that but I
mean if it's kind of ridiculous I think
too that it's kind of ridiculous when
the left says that we should take our
religious beliefs out of politics
because at the end of the day everything
that is moral on the philosophical sense
is because of God it is the dot of God
there is no morality if there is no God
and so if we're talking about the laws
in our nation what governs right and
wrong and justice those are all be gods
of the judeo-christian tradition of
morals there's no way we can remove that
unless we fundamentally mean unless we
wanted to fundamentally change our
system and we've been the most
successful the most just the most
prosperous system on earth why would we
change that okay so in just one second I
want to ask you a final question that is
what do you think is the biggest problem
facing the United States if you want to
hear those wheelers answer however you
have to be a daily water subscriber to
subscribe head on over to daily wire.com
click Subscribe and you can hear the end
of our conversation over there well Liz
I really appreciate you stopping by the
book is tipping points everybody should
go check it out thank you
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy boring associate producer Colton
Haas
our guests are booked by Kaitlyn Maynard
post-production is supervised by Alex
Singaram editing by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Kamino
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
title graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
[Music]